l'échange de cet après-midi avec vous et
donc nous poursuivons les travaux de
notre commission d'enquête par
l'audition de Monsieur Michael Danon
directeur de market access et des
affaires institutionnelles du groupe
Pierre Fabre ainsi que Monsieur Marc
urbain directeur industrie et Vincent
Guiraud chaumes directeur de la filiale
France medical du même groupe je vous
remercie messieurs directeur de vous
êtes mobilisés le laboratoire pierre Fab
créa Castres en 1962 par un pharmacien
biologiste tarnet est un acteur
historique de l'industrie française des
produits de santé actifs à la fois dans
le domaine de la dermato cosmétique et
dans celui du médicament de prescription
et aujourd'hui un des tout premiers
groupes pharmaceutiques français son
ancrage sur un territoire le sud-ouest
de la France qui concentre la majorité
de ces sites de recherche et de
production ne s'est jamais démenti
malgré un fort développement
international la moitié de la
cinquantaine de sites français du groupe
continuent à se situer dans le Tarn
département dont il est de loin le
premier employeur il est aussi l'un des
trois premiers employeurs privés
d'Occitanie en tant qu'acteur majeur de
la chaîne industrielle du médicament et
observateur privilégié des carences qui
visiblement altèrent le bon
fonctionnement de cette chaîne il était
naturel que nous vous entendions dans le
cadre de notre travail sur les tensions
rupture d'approvisionnement qui frappent
désormais de façon chronique les
médicaments qui sont prescrits et
consommés dans notre pays et d'ailleurs
pour un sujet total de transparence
vis-à-vis de vous préciser que bien
évidemment je suis sénateur mais je suis
également pharmacien d'officine en
activité
parmi les grands groupes pharmaceutiques
français vous êtes tous spécialement
associés je l'ai dit à l'idée d'un
ancrage régional fort avec une belle
équipe de rugby aussi vous portez la
volonté de maîtriser l'ensemble de votre
chaîne de production et
choisi de conforter plutôt que de
l'abandonner la stratégie du fondateur
du groupe selian France n'est certain
made in France sur lequel vous continuez
volontiers
vous êtes donc particulièrement bien
passé pour nous dire en quoi ce choix
selon vous va de soi ou est-il au
contraire en péril je précise qu'un
autre connaissance 100% de vos équipes
de recherche sont situées en France et
que plus de 90% de votre production de
médicaments et de dermato cosmétiques
est effectué en France alors même que
votre revenu provient audietière de vos
activités à l'international
la crise covid ayant donné un nouvel
élan à une telle orientation vous
semblez vouloir la pérenniser comme le
montre l'exemple du rapatriement de la
production du principe actif de votre
antique cancéreux mectovie dans l'usine
de chimie fin de Gaillac vous nous direz
notamment si cet ancrage et cette
stratégie de maîtrise complète de
l'approvisionnement pourrait être
généralisée et servir de modèle à une
industrie pharmaceutique véritablement
souveraine
je vais vous céder la parole messieurs
pour un propos introductif et vous
présenter vous présenterez votre analyse
de la situation et formulerez vous
recommandations pour y remédier puis
madame Laurence Cohen rapporteur de
notre commission d'enquête vous posera
une première série de questions comme
vous l'aurez compris notre commission
d'enquête en tant obtenir des réponses
étayées à ces questions précises je
précise également que cette audition est
diffusée en direct sur le site internet
du Sénat elle fera l'objet d'un
compte-rendu publié avant de vous donner
la parole je vous rappelle qu'un faux
témoignage devant une commission dans le
quête parlementaire et passible des
peines prévues aux articles 434 13 434
et 434 15 du code pénal je vous invite
messieurs à prêter serment de dire
toutes les vérité rien que la vérité en
levant la main droite et en disant je le
jure monsieur Danon
monsieur
urbain
et Monsieur Giraud Jean mail
je vous remercie
monsieur le vice-président madame la
rapporteur mesdames et messieurs
nous souhaitons tout d'abord vous
remercier de nous donner la possibilité
d'échanger avec vous sur la question des
ruptures de médicaments en tant que
entreprise pharmaceutique c'est bien
évidemment une question particulièrement
importante pour nous car ce qui est en
jeu c'est la possibilité pour les
patients d'avoir accès à leur
donc nous sommes très heureux d'avoir
cette opportunité de pouvoir discuter et
de témoigner devant cette commission de
l'expérience du groupe Pierre Fabre
monsieur le vice-président vous avez
bien voulu rappeler un certain nombre
d'éléments importants concernant notre
entreprise je vous en remercie je me
permettrai juste en guise de courte
introduction de revenir sur quelques-uns
des ces éléments et puis peut-être de
rajouter d'autres spécificités qui me
semblent importantes à mentionner à la
Commission
effectivement comme vous l'avez indiqué
le groupe irfabre c'est le résultat
d'une très belle histoire scientifique
et industrielle fondée par Monsieur
Pierre Fabre qui était pharmacien qui
avait son officine à Castres le groupe
aujourd'hui représente un chiffre
d'affaires de 2 milliards 7 près de
10000 collaborateurs dans le monde
41 implantations dans des pays à
l'international et plus de 100 pays dans
lesquels nos produits sont
commercialisés et comme vous l'avez
indiqué nous avons deux types
d'activités d'une part dans le
dermocosmétique façon de marques bien
connue des consommateurs français et
bien sûr dans le médicament et dans le
médicament nous avons un portefeuille
équilibré avec à la fois des produits
matures qui sont utilisés communément
par les patients français depuis de
nombreuses années mais également et nous
en sommes très fiers des produits très
innovants notamment dans le domaine de
la cancérologie on pourra bien sûr y
revenir
je voudrais aussi rappeler parce que
c'est quelque chose qui pour nous est
très important
la spécificité capitalistique du groupe
le groupe Pierre Fabre le capital du
groupe pierrefargue dans les mains d'une
fondation reconnue du TT public et je
pense que nous sommes en France le seul
exemple que ce soit dans le domaine de
l'industrie pharmaceutique ou de manière
plus générale dans l'ensemble des
secteurs économiques c'était une volonté
de Monsieur Fabre qui avait décidé qu'à
sa disparition l'ensemble de ses biens
et dont le groupe qu'il avait fondé
revienne à la Fondation qu'il avait
lui-même créé et aujourd'hui 86% les
capitales de l'entreprise appartient à
cette fondation Pierre Fabre le reste du
capital est réparti pour une part en
actionnariat salarié 8,6% et là aussi
c'était une volonté de Monsieur Fabre de
permettre aux collaborateurs du groupe
de participer non seulement aux
résultats d'entreprise mais à sa
structure capitalistique et le reste du
capital étant autofinancement
juste pour vous donner un chiffre
actuellement
l'actionnariat salarié a été déployée
dans douze pays ou dans lesquels nous
sommes présents et en France qui a été
évidemment le premier pays dans lequel
nous avons développé cette cette
actionnariat salarié
87% des collaborateurs Pierre Fabre en
France sont participent à ce programme
d'actionnariat salarié dans la
gouvernance de la Fondation pierrefam
nous avons d'ailleurs deux représentants
de l'État qui veille et qui participent
à la stratégie du groupe alors ça
signifie quoi ça signifie que les
résultats et les profits que
l'entreprise réalise peuvent être
utilisés bien sûr pour développer
l'entreprise pour ses projets
d'investissement que ce soit dans la R&D
que ce soit dans la capacité
industrielle et on pourra revenir en
détail là dessus tout à l'heure dans la
prise en compte de la sonaria salariée
que je mentionnais et puis et c'est
important dans les actions menées par la
Fondation Pierre Fabre action menée
principalement en Asie du Sud-Est et en
Afrique noire que ce soit de la
formation de professionnels de santé que
ce soit des actions destinées à aider
des programmes de développement dans le
en matière sanitaire localement
vous avez insisté et je pense que c'est
effectivement très important sur le
choix constant de l'entreprise de la
France effectivement je vous indiquais
que nous avons
9600 collaborateurs dans le monde 56% de
ses collaborateurs sont en France avec
comme vous l'avez dit 100% notre
recherche en France et
95% de la production industrielle en
France le 95% couvrant la fois la partie
dermocosmétique et la partie médicament
nous avons 7 sites de production en
France deux sites de distribution et
plus de 1500 collaborateurs qui
travaillent dans les sites de production
industrielle
donc voilà quelques-unes des
spécificités du groupe pour lequel nous
travaillons tous les trois et pour
évoquer la question des
tensions et des ruptures que nous avons
subies si vous le voulez bien monsieur
le Président je souhaiterais passer la
parole à mon collègue Vincent Guiro
sommeil donc qui est patron de la fidél
France
donc pour parler pour entrer dans le vif
du sujet et pour parler des ruptures et
des tensions je voudrais tout d'abord
dire que le laboratoire Pierre Fabre
depuis deux ans un principalement été
confronté à des tensions et quelques
ruptures et je reviendrai sur sur ces
ruptures et puis il y a un élément
explicatif c'est les tensions les
ruptures sont souvent multifactorielles
et je sais que vous avez rencontré
beaucoup de laboratoires qui vous ont
énoncé toutes les toutes les causes de
possibles pour ces ruptures et ses et
ses tensions l'avant-papier à Fabre a
été confronté à un élément
supplémentaire c'est une cyberattaque de
très grande ampleur en 2021 qui a nous a
obligé à arrêter la production pendant 6
semaines cela venait après après le
covid et dans un environnement où les
limites capacités sont vite atteindre
nous avons eu beaucoup de
ni beaucoup de temps pour rattraper et
pour être en capacité de rétablir des
stocks de sécurité absolument
nécessaires pour pour
la distribution de nos médicaments si je
veux rentrer plus dans les détails nous
avons dans le groupe Pierre Fabre 14
amitm c'est-à-dire des médicaments
d'intérêt thérapeutique majeurs et deux
de ces médicaments ont été confrontés à
des problématiques de rupture mais du
fait de la production française et un
accord avec la NSM nous avons ce castré
c'est le terme c'est le terme
les quantités nécessaires pour que aucun
patient français ne soit en rupture de
traitement ce sont des traitements
d'oncologie et donc aucun patient
français n'a dû à subir on a dû subir
des problèmes de rupture du fait de
sanitm ceci est la conséquence de
du travail en commun avec un SM et le
fait de la production française
en ce qui concerne les les tensions que
nous avons rencontrées dans d'autres sur
d'autres médicaments nous avons eu en
place une politique
particulière nous avons deux canaux de
distribution un canal par de la vente
directe et un canal par le biais des
grossistes et pour assurer une
distribution la plus homogène de ces
produits en tension ou tous les quotas
nous avons arrêté la vente directe et
nous avons nous avons développé pour ces
produits là uniquement la distribution
par les grossistes c'est qui nous permet
un maillage territorial de de plus
grande importance une autre
particularité du laboratoire Pierre
Fabre c'est que nous avons gardé et peu
de laboratoires aujourd'hui le font
encore
des équipes nombreuses qui vont à la
rencontre des médecins à la rencontre
des pharmaciens nous avons sur la
filiale France médicament plus de 300
collaborateurs qui visitent les médecin
qui visitent les pharmaciens et par ce
canal là nous avons en direct informer
les médecins et les pharmaciens des
tensions que nous avions et des
précautions que nous devions nous
devions prendre donc que ça soit au
niveau de la distribution que ce soit au
niveau de la communication et puis en
accord avec la NSM nous avons tout fait
pendant ces deux dernières années pour
limiter au maximum l'impact de pour les
patients français de séruption et de ses
tensions puis Marc urbain reviendra plus
en détail sur les sur des cas
particuliers et vous montrera comment
nous avons agi devant ces difficultés là
oui donc monsieur vice-président madame
la rapporteur comme l'a dit Vincent ou
Michael effectivement on a subi des
tensions sur différents types de
produits des tensions qui sont
aujourd'hui de 3 facteurs donc il y a un
facteur qui est clairement le facteur
spécifique à pierrefap qui a été la
cyberattaque qui est arrivé après le
facteur covid et les stop and go qu'on a
eu par rapport au covid qui a du coup
aggravé la situation c'est de ces deux
situations là on fait que nous sommes
retrouvés à consommer la totalité de nos
stocks de sécurité pour continuer à
fournir et à livrer les marchés le
marché français mais les autres marchés
et là dessus une crise sans sans
précédent de mémoire d'industrielle de
ma part sur tout ce qui est chaînes
d'approvisionnement que ce soit des
principes actifs mais que ce soit aussi
des composants permettant la fabrication
des principes actifs sur la totalité du
marché crise qui est arrivée en plus de
ces deux crises que l'on a eu chez
Pierre Fabre et qui a de ce fait
complexifier la situation à titre
d'exemple
pour illustrer mon propos
on utilise du PVC pour faire les
blisters donc pour pour faire le
packaging des comprimés que l'on que
l'on derrière commercialise et on met à
disposition des patients
le PVC aujourd'hui il y a une crise
mondiale du PVC on est passé de six
semaines à 40 semaines de délai
d'approvisionnement tout ça pour des
raisons de concentration de moyens de
production pour des raisons de demande
supérieures à l'offre industrielle même
exemple aussi sur le carton donc tous
nos produits sont livrés dans des étuis
le carton a subi aussi une crise avec
des stops notamment en Chine avec le
carton recyclé qui n'était plus
disponible
il y a eu aussi un transfert des besoins
du carte du plastique vers de
l'emballage carton qui est vu comme
étant plus écologique et plus
respectueux de l'environnement donc une
demande qui s'est translatée de la
partie plastique vers le parti carton et
du coup nous nos fabricants et nos
fournisseurs principaux de de
d'étui ne pouvait plus approvisionner en
carton et de ce fait augmenter les
délais d'approvisionnement donc on a
vraiment trois trois éléments qui qui
peuvent résumer là je parle de Pierre
Fabre c'est vraiment cette ce le covid
ça c'est un peu tout le monde a subi ce
problème là la cyberatta qui a fait que
on a été de fait encore plus pénalisé et
ensuite la crise
d'approvisionnement des différentes des
différentes matières ou des composants
là qui est aussi globalement
nous sommes bien sûr à votre disposition
pour toutes les questions de la
commission merci monsieur le Président
merci messieurs pour votre propos
laminaire donc j'aurai un certain nombre
de questions à vous à vous poser ma
première question vous avez notamment
dénoncer un prix de médicaments
remboursé tellement bas en France que
pour reprendre les propos de votre
directeur général je cite quand un
médicament est exporté à moins de 50% il
est en risque ce qui sauvent les
produits ce sont les exportations fort
de cette règle avez-vous donc déjà eu
l'occasion ou en tout cas d'abandonner
la fabrication de certains médicaments
ou leur commercialisation en France
une question qui est corollaire c'est
par ailleurs l'interdiction temporaire
des exportations de médicaments de
médicaments pardon en tension ou en
rupture a-t-elle eu donc un impact sur
votre activité contenu donc
des propos de votre directeur et de la
politique que vous semblez mené ma
deuxième question concerne donc plus
particulièrement le prix des médicaments
on a pu constater lors de nos de nos
auditions que effectivement il est
reproché un prix très bas des
médicaments matures très bas voire trop
bas des prix qui s'envolent pour les
médicaments innovants et donc vous vous
avez demandé une augmentation des
médicaments d'imatures et un moratoire
sur les baisses de prix d'ailleurs déjà
été décidé nous sommes au niveau de la
commission
d'enquête
interrogative et nous voudrions avoir
des précisions sur le fait que de toute
façon il vous l'avez dit les ruptures
les tensions ont des causes
multifactorielles c'est évident sinon ce
serait trop simple
les prix des médicaments il faut
peut-être aller plus loin parce que
parallèlement on a on a pu constater que
par exemple en Suisse où les prix
notamment des antibiotiques sont quatre
fois cinq fois plus haut que les prix
pratiqués en France il y a eu les mêmes
ruptures tension de médicaments donc ça
ne sont pas seulement les prix qui
peuvent dans ce cas là être mis en cause
donc qu'est-ce que vous vous avancez
comme comme analyse comme comme
proposition
sur sur ces questions là par ailleurs
nous avons besoin aussi d'avoir votre
analyse votre regard sur les politiques
de régulation des dépenses de
médicaments et nous avons pu avoir là
encore dans des auditions précédentes
des remarques concernant la clause de
sauvegarde qui prend une place qui est
de plus en plus importante et en tout
cas qui est critiqué justement par son
caractère indifférencier et notamment
parce que elle s'attaque si je puis dire
où elle se pose aussi pour les produits
matures qui sont déjà particulièrement
bas donc là encore comment est-ce que
vous vous voulez vous souhaitez vous
proposer de faire évoluer donc ce
système pour à la fois donc permettre de
limiter les phénomènes de pénurie et
même de les empêcher mais également
d'empêcher une dérive incontrôlée des
dépenses donc comment on arrive à tenir
les deux bouts les deux bouts de la
chaîne j'ai parlé des d'exportation tout
à l'heure et j'aimerais savoir si vous
êtes impacté par l'existence de
shortliner et d'exportation donc
parallèle qui pour certains constituent
un réel un réel problème enfin les deux
dernières questions
vous avez est-ce que vous avez eu
l'occasion l'opportunité de saisir le
CEPS pour l'activation des articles 27
et 28 de l'accord cadre qui permettent
effectivement à un laboratoire d'obtenir
une stabilité du prix faciale en
contrepartie d'investissement réalisé
dans les dernières périodes ou à venir
dans l'Union européenne ou d'obtenir
même une hausse des prix pour une
spécialité qui serait menacée donc ça
c'est une opportunité qui est offerte
par ces par ces deux articles mais qui
passe pas tellement mis en activation
d'après les différentes auditions que
nous avons pu avoir enfin ma toute
dernière question concerne donc j'en ai
une autre et j'ai perdu mes papiers mais
j'ai retrouvé voilà il est là
il a été aussi fait devant nous quelques
difficultés
concernant l'Agence nationale de
sécurité du médicament qui d'une part
est un partenaire fiable et sur lesquels
peuvent s'appuyer les différents
laboratoires mais en même temps quand
les pour un certain nombre de
médicaments qui sont en tension qui
menacent d'être en rupture il y a des
contingentements qui sont à ce moment-là
organisés et la semaine dernière nous
avons pu auditionner un laboratoire qui
a posé cette question un peu paradoxale
c'est-à-dire à la fois être obligé de
subir des contingentements quand par
ailleurs et bien on manque de ces mêmes
médicaments dans dans les différentes
régions de notre pays si je ne prends
que la France donc voilà les questions
que je voulais vous poser messieurs
merci d'avance
bien beaucoup de questions et beaucoup
de questions importantes
et je vais essayer de vous apporter les
réponses à plus précises possibles et
peut-être sur certaines questions je
laisserai mais mes collègues mes
collègues répondent je les ai toutes
notées madame la rapporteur je vais pas
forcément suivre l'ordre de vos
questions
vous nous avez interrogé sur
l'utilisation d'une des dispositions de
l'accord cadre signé entre le lait mais
les ceps sur la possibilité de
revendiquer des hausses de prix donc qui
est prévu par l'article 28 oui nous
avons déposé des dossiers il y a deux
mois auprès du CEPS pour être précis
nous avons déposé des dossiers sur 17
présentations
ces dossier sont en cours d'instruction
donc bien évidemment je ne pourrais rien
en dire actuellement
ce que nous savons et je crois que se
l'avait été indiqué par
les représentants du LEM quand vous les
aviez auditionnés c'est que par rapport
au à l'ensemble le dossier présenté au
CEPS il y en a pas énormément qui
recevait une suite favorable ou avec des
augmentations voilà c'est je ne fais que
reprendre ce qui a pu dire par le même
en ce qui concerne les dossiers Pierre
Fabre ils sont en cours d'instruction et
bien évidemment je n'ai aucun
commentaire à faire sur ce sujet
peut-être pas si j'ai un petit
commentaire non non pas sur ces dossiers
bien sûr mais sur la rédaction de
l'article 28 l'article 28 résulte donc
de cet accord 4 qui a dessiné en 2021 un
moment où le pays ne connaissait pas
d'inflation et donc il a été rédigé et
accepté signé donc à la fois par le
président du CEPS et par le président du
LEM dans un certain contexte économique
qui n'est plus le même et donc nous
pensons qu'il faudrait revoir
l'écriture de cet article pour tenir
compte de la situation économique avec
une forte inflation qui a des
conséquences bien sûr pour toutes les
entreprises
et la rédaction actuelle de l'article 28
est très restrictive sur les
possibilités pour le CEPS d'accorder des
hausses de prix donc on souhaite pouvoir
rediscuter avec le comité économique de
la rédaction de cet article quand je dis
nous c'est l'industrie pharmaceutique
donc vous savez que le laboratoire
Pierre Fabre est membre du LEM et aussi
membre fondateurs du G5 et donc vous
aviez eu l'occasion d'auditionner le
président du G5 je crois que c'était
exprimé sur un certain nombre de sujets
autre article important qui a été voté
par l'Assemblée Sénat et l'article 65 de
la haute financement pour la sécurité
sociale pour 2022 qui complète les
critères de fixation du prix par le
comité économique
nous sommes très satisfaits de cette
disposition puisque elle permet au CEPS
de tenir compte de l'implantation
de la production et donc de la sécurité
de l'approvisionnement
nous regrettons que il faille autant de
temps pour le comité économique de
finaliser la doctrine d'application de
cet article puisque au jour
d'aujourd'hui la doctrine du CEPS a été
communiquée s'agissant des produits
nouveaux mais comme vous le savez nous
sommes en partie concernés par des
produits matures qui sont sur le marché
depuis pas mal d'années et sur lequel
nous avons cette préoccupation de deux
niveaux de prix et donc nous souhaitons
que le CEPS puisse finaliser sa doctrine
d'application de l'article 65 qui a été
maintenant adopté par le Parlement il y
a près de près de 18 mois
vous avez également mentionné la clause
de sauvegarde alors je ne serai
certainement pas le premier en parler je
sais que pas mal de d'entreprises qui
ont été auditionnées par votre
commission ont pu évoquer cette
préoccupation
effectivement
le problème c'est que le montant de la
clause sauvegarde que nous devons payer
a augmenté de manière considérable pour
le laboratoire Pierre Fabre entre 2019
et 2021 le montant a été multiplié
quasiment par 6 et si je reprends
l'ensemble de l'industrie ça c'est les
chiffres que vous avez cité LEM en 2021
le montant à payer a été de 1 milliard
100 et nous attendons une facture de 2
milliards pour l'année 2022 à payer en
2023 voilà donc bien sûr c'est des
montants considérables qui pèsent sur la
rentabilité des entreprises et
s'agissant du groupe Pierre Fabre ça
veut dire que
notre rentabilité rejoindre et que les
actions que nous finançons notamment à
travers la Fondation auront moins moins
de ressources alors vous vous avez
évoqué aussi la question du niveau des
prix
c'est effectivement une préoccupation
que nous avons
nous avons fait quelques comparaisons
entre les prix pratiqués en France et
les prix pratiquée dans nos chaînes nos
voisins européens et nous constatons et
c'est des chiffres que nous avons
regardé en début de cette année des
écarts des écarts très importants entre
la France et l'Allemagne ça n'étonnera
personne mais également entre la France
et l'Italie
où là nous avons des prix inférieurs
notamment pour les produits en
cancérologie que ce soit des produits en
cancérologie des produits nature ou pour
les nouveaux produits innovants que nous
commercialisons dans ce domaine là donc
question question des prix alors vous
avez posé une question très importante
qui est la relation potentielle entre le
niveau des prix et les risques de
rupture
c'est pas une question simple puisque je
pense que tous les toutes les personnes
que vous avez pu auditionner où l'on dit
les ruptures sont multifactorielles et
donc imputer la question de la rupture
uniquement un problème de prix serait
intellectuellement inexact et
factuellement faux en revanche
il est clair que le niveau des prix va
impacter la rentabilité et donc notre
capacité d'investissement c'est à dire
que si nous commercialisons des produits
avec un prix sur lesquels les marges
sont faibles notre capacité
d'investissement notamment dans l'outil
industriel va être compromise
et
il y a donc un effet à moyen à long
terme indirect entre le niveau des prix
et la capacité d'entreprise à renouveler
son appareil de production que ce soit
des usines que ce soit des chaînes de
production ou soit des machines et avec
des possibilités de
rupture et ça marque pourra revenir sur
quelques exemples de produits pour
lesquels nous avons besoin
industriellement parlant de renouveler
notre notre outil industriel et bien sûr
dans le calcul de rentabilité on va
prendre en compte le coût de l'achat de
la machine le coût de l'installation et
un regard les prix les prix que nous
pouvons escompter pour la production de
cette machine et le dernier point que je
voudrais peut-être évoquer c'est la
question de l'horizon temporelle
une décision industrielle c'est de
nombreuses années de nombreuses années
avant
entre le moment où on décide de conduire
un investissement industriel maman ou la
chaîne va sortir les boîtes de
médicaments il se passe plusieurs années
et la difficulté que nous avons dans le
contexte
actuel en France c'est la
l'impossibilité ou la quasi
impossibilité d'avoir de la
prévisibilité la prévisibilité que soit
sur la clause de sauvegarde ou sur le
niveau des prix sur la clause de
sauvegarde
je dirais qu'on a une information sur le
montant à payer extrêmement tardivement
et de quelques mois et sur le niveau des
prix c'est pareil nous avons le total du
des baisses demandées
mais proposés par le gouvernement est
soumis à la discussion au Parlement dans
le cas du PLFSS quelques mois avant que
le CPS s'empare du chiffre et déroule la
mécanique qui est sa mission et je crois
que Philippe Bouilloud l'avait
parfaitement expliqué quand vous l'avez
auditionné très bien simplement nous
nous avons à prendre des décisions
industrielles
sur cinq ans et au-delà et donc nous
n'avons aucune prévisibilité possible
sur le prix de nos médicaments à cet
horizon là donc nous avons une vraie
difficulté économique donc pour répondre
à votre question très importante et
cruciale
je ne vous dirai pas que nous avons
arrêté la commercialisation de produits
en France pour apprendre de prix mais je
vous dirais que des prix bas ont des
conséquences un moyen long terme
dommageable et impact notre capacité
d'investir dans l'outil industriel en
France
des séquestration
ça sera plus facile donc je vais vous
parler des conséquences de la
séquestration et de l'importation
parallèle que vous avez vous allez voir
Madame
les conséquences de la sécrétion je suis
médecin et industriel donc il y a un
avantage pour le patient français c'est
une évidence lorsqu'on sait que lorsque
l'on bloque les des quantités de
produits qui sont en tension ou en
rupture pour le marché français ça a une
conséquence c'est que le patient
européen peut notamment en oncologie
aura plus de mal à avoir son traitement
donc c'est pas satisfaisant c'est une
réponse
à un moment donné de vente devant une
urgence mais ce n'est pas un axe
satisfaisant que de dire qu'un patient
français par rapport à un patient
étranger voilà donc ça c'est pas
satisfaisant juste une remarque nous
n'avons pas eu besoin d'utiliser cette
méthode là depuis plus d'un an avec
Pierre Fabre ce dont je vous parlais en
introduction c'était en début en début
2022 l'importation parallèle est-ce que
l'importation parallèle à un impact sur
les ruptures alors nous chez Pierre
Fabre en France nous n'avons pas été
impactés parce que nos produits qui ont
qui subissent de l'importation parallèle
parce que leur prix est beaucoup plus
bas que dans le dans les pays dans les
pays voisins ne sont pas des produits en
tension mais
avant de travailler en France j'ai
travaillé en Europe
dans beaucoup de pays et des pays avec
des prix très différents et avec un
différentiel de prix particulièrement
important par rapport à d'autres pays
voilà à cause de l'importation parallèle
des cas de rupture parce que ces
distributeurs là préfèrent parfois
prendre des produits acheter des
produits à des prix bas et les revendre
à des prix plus élevés donc oui
l'importation parallèle et
potentiellement un facteur de tension de
tension et de rupture
vous ai parlé de la NSM partenaire
fiable je reprends vos termes
exigeant nous n'avons pas été
nous a pas demandé de contingenter nos
produits mais ça peut aussi se
comprendre parce que aujourd'hui si vous
avez si vous avez des produits de
première nécessité qui se retrouvent
très forte tension vous pouvez avoir des
acteurs qui
achètent ou
récupérer plus de produits que
nécessaire sur le territoire et donc je
vous parlais tout à l'heure de notre
stratégie de passer par les grossistes
pour avoir
une distribution homogène l'action de la
NSM avec le contingentement c'est bien
pour éviter que des surstocks se fassent
de façon artificielle et aggraver une
situation de pays de pénurie c'est comme
ça que je comprends l'action de la NSM
et peut-être en complément de ce qui a
été dit par rapport à une vision
industrielle et pour rebondir sur le
phénomène prix est-ce que je disais
Michael effectivement le prix n'est pas
la raison de rupture par contre
effectivement en tant qu'industriel on a
besoin d'une visibilité moyen terme de
stabilité importante pour pouvoir
définir des investissements tels que
tels que expliqué et je vais vous donner
deux exemples le premier exemple c'est
un traitement pour le sevrage tabagique
que l'on fait sur un site dans le Gers
qui s'appelle nico-pass donc c'est une
pastille à sucer avec avec différents
dosages de nicotine qui permettent de
pouvoir faire le traitement de sevrage
tabagique on est sur des processus qui
sont je dirais entre le semi artisanal
et le industriel donc des processus
assez anciens pour pouvoir répondre à la
demande du marché on a besoin d'investir
et de basculer sur des lignes beaucoup
plus performantes de fabrication en
continu
et quand on voit la perspective de
baisse de prix de rembourser sur ce type
de produit là la question se pose
vraiment de se dire est-ce qu'on va y
aller ou pas Pierre Fabre a décidé d'y
aller et on a décidé d'investir on a
d'ailleurs aussi sollicité quelques
subventions notamment au niveau des
territoires d'industrie qui nous a sur
une partie du projet mais c'est un
projet qui est dans l'investissement
d'un peu moins de 2 millions d'euros
c'est un projet qui va durer entre 3 et
4 ans suivant la durée de réponse
d'homologation de la variation qu'on va
faire sur le dossier le dossier
de notoriétation de mise sur le marché
donc vous voyez c'est cet exemple là
illustre ce besoin de de visibilité de
stabilité et à un moment donné quand on
a lancé un Athis-Mons ne pas se
retrouver face à une baisse de prix de
remboursement puisqu'on a décidé de
rester dans la catégorie des produits
remboursés pour pour ce pour ce produit
là
donc c'est vraiment de la stabilité
visibilité moyen terme merci messieurs
Emilienne Patricia
aujourd'hui être en quelques questions
posées je vais dire que je suis assez
matrice locale de l'étape puisque je
suis toulousaine et que je vais
d'ailleurs demander à vous rencontrer à
vous voir sur le site de l'Oncopole
et donc effectivement la Fondation le
l'attachement de Pierre Fabre son
territoire Darné etc ou toulousain
d'ailleurs parce qu'il y a beaucoup de
choses sur Toulouse et sur mon secteur
de linopole
je colle bien moi je voulais revenir
juste sur
chose que vous venez d'évoquer juste à
l'instant d'abord savoir bien qu'elle
est votre politique en R&D parce que je
sais que c'est un département important
pour pour Fabre et ensuite justement
dans ce domaine là est-ce que quels sont
les montants des aides publiques parce
que c'est important bien sûr pour vous
et
si vous avez des bons temps à nous
donner le crédit pour recherche le
cirque ça représente quoi que est-ce que
vous avez répondu à des appels à projets
par rapport à France 2030
si vous pouviez nous donner des choses
précises serait très intéressant
c'est quand même inquiétant quand on
parle de médicaments et surtout le
cancer c'est vrai qu'à un moment donné
je sais que des gens nous regardent et
il y a des inquiétudes chacun pense
comment est-ce qu'il va être fourni à un
moment donné et soigner et à savoir
aussi si d'autres entreprises de votre
niveau font les à peu près les mêmes
médicaments ou les mêmes médicaments je
suis pas une spécialiste j'ai pas
travaillé dans dans des laboratoires
donc vous dire est-ce que ils sont ils
s'orientent vers d'autres fabricants ou
mais c'est vrai qu'aujourd'hui on voit
aussi une recrudescence de de cancer je
l'entends autour de moi j'entends les
médecins en parler j'entends des
gynécologues donc vous dire que c'est
vrai moi ça m'interpelle et comment vous
travaillez avec la santé entre
guillemets dans dans notre pays comment
vous faites en sorte pour aussi pour
anticiper et soigner parce que c'est
aussi votre rôle je pense les Français
alors je vais revenir d'abord sur la
question de la recherche comme je
l'indiquais tout à l'heure 100% de la
recherche du groupe et est effectué en
France et notamment comme vous l'avez
mentionné madame massénatrice à
l'encopole nous avons en revue notre
stratégie de recherche récemment pour la
focaliser sur un nombre plus limité de
domaine thérapeutiques nous sommes un
groupe de taille intermédiaires la
recherche de nouvelles molécules le coût
de plus en plus cher et on ne peut pas
être avoir des ambitions trop larges et
donc nous avons décidé de nous
revocaliser sur la cancérologie et voilà
et en tout cas certains domaines de la
cancérologie où il y a déjà des très
gros acteurs qui sont présents la
dermatologie et l'orientation un petit
peu nouvelle les maladies rares puisque
là aussi il y a des besoins
considérables de la population non
couverts et sur laquelle la possibilité
de développer le nouveau traitement nous
semble répondre à un besoin de santé
publique et et possibilités pour nous de
poursuivre notre croissance
alors nous nous vérifions comme
l'ensemble des entreprises du secteur du
crédit pour recherche et je dirais que
pour nous c'est quelque chose un élément
très important de contribution au
financement de notre recherche
je n'ai pas le montant ici du crédit
pour recherche que dont nous bénéficions
mais bien évidemment nous pouvons vous
l'indiquer par écrit dans les tous
prochains jours
voilà et
je pense que l'ensemble des acteurs
intervenus et additionné par la
Commission ont pu rappeler l'importance
du crédit impôt recherche dans
l'économie générale du secteur et son
utilité
s'agissant de votre question madame sur
les les médicaments
sur un certain domaine thérapeutique
nous avons d'autres il y a qui
fournissent des des médicaments je
dirais ayant la même indication mais
chaque médicament a sa spécificité et
comme vous le savez même quand on fait
des variations sur les excipients du
même médicament le patient peut réagir
différemment donc c'est toujours très
très compliqué
mais il y a certains de médicaments sur
lesquels nous nous sommes les seuls les
seuls présents d'où la responsabilité
imminente qui est la nôtre de nous
assurer d'avoir la capacité à tout
moment de répondre aux besoins des
patients et donc ce qui expliquait
Vincent là-dessus et crucial parce que
nous sommes parfaitement conscients de
cette responsabilité et nous devons
prendre
en amont toutes les mesures pour pouvoir
assumer cette responsabilité
je vous ai parlé de la classification
des MITM la classification des MITM et
et faite pour que il y ait une attention
toute particulière sur ce type de
médicament qui ne peut être remplacé
facilement par d'autres par d'autres par
d'autres produits avec notamment la
nécessité d'avoir des stocks plus
importants pour ces produits là que pour
des produits qui qui sont
en concurrence avec des d'autres
produits qui ont une efficience à peu
près à peu près équivalente donc sur les
MITM donc la plupart des produits
d'ontologie il y a une attention
particulière je vous ai donné un exemple
au début d'un produit en oncologie il y
a un an un accident industriel peut
toujours arriver mais on fait le
nécessaire pour que ça arrive le que ça
n'arrive pas ou que ça n'arrive plus on
a les stocks suffisants pour que aucun
patient de ce type de traitement ne soit
ne soit en rupture et c'est une classe
ce sont des médicaments qui ont encore
une fois une attention particulière à la
fois de la part des industriels de
Pierre Fernand particulier et des
agences
et après quand on peut sur du moyen
terme on essaie de sécuriser la Supply
Chain donc au niveau industriel et c'est
là où on peut donner l'exemple on a deux
médicaments braftovénile qui sont
justement pour le traitement des
traitements du mélanome en Ticky
cancéreux ou on a décidé de
réinternaliser une partie de la chaîne
de fabrication et de avec l'avantage que
Pierre Fabre a d'avoir un site
industriel chimique qui permet de faire
de la synthèse à partir de à partir de
différents éléments donc on réintègre
une partie de sa fabrication qui est clé
puisque c'est le l'actif l'ingrédient
actif du médicament pour que l'on
sécurise un peu que l'on soit moins
dépendant de fournisseurs qui sont en
Europe et voir en Asie pour ce pour pour
ce cas de figure là mais pareil c'est un
c'est du moyen terme là je vous parle
d'un projet ou l'investissement est à
peu près de 5 millions d'euros
industriels et c'est un projet qui va
durer à peu près 5 ans entre le moment
où comme le disait Michael le moment où
on a décidé de d'y aller et le moment où
on aura le site de Gaillac qui fera
cette cette synthèse là et ce
fabrication la valider par les autorités
de mise sur le marché il se passe 5 ans
j'ai une petite question subsidiaire
c'est toujours effectivement on a
constaté aussi que il y a une
consommation extrêmement importante des
médicaments notamment en France il y a
eu un développement un peu plus un peu
plus important après le covid alors là
encore multi multifactorielle
et du coup un des arguments aussi qui
qui est donné là par rapport au prix
trop bas notamment des médicaments
matures c'est de dire que sur le marché
français et d'une manière générale sur
le marché européen il y avait un
rattrapage
volumétrique est-ce que vous vous
confirmez ou pas
il y a il y a aujourd'hui des
produits matures ou produits aussi de
première nécessité c'est à dire que
l'innovation c'est très important en
médecine mais le soin du quotidien est
aussi un élément fondamental de la santé
et il est vrai que après la période du
covid des thérapeutiques qui avaient été
un peu délaissés parce qu'il n'était pas
dans la priorité à la fois de nos
soignants et et des patients en effet en
effet sont en effet redéveloppés on a
beaucoup parlé des problèmes
de dépression on a beaucoup parlé de
pathologies de prévention qu'on ne
l'avait qu'on avait laissé de côté au
moment au moment du covid et de tout ce
qui s'est passé c'est sûr que nous avons
vu un retour on va dire une réflexion
plus globale de la santé de la part des
Français et des soignants et en effet
certains produits je préfère de première
nécessité ont été ont
été plus utilisés que que du covid mais
ça me paraît être de la bonne médecine
et de la bonne de la bonne santé quand
on voit quand on voit les indications
pour lesquelles ils ont été utilisés
au niveau donc du rattrapage du volume
par rapport au prix
les volumes les volumes pour certains
erres thérapeutiques ont été fortement
ont évolué mais les prix étant tellement
réglementé et réguler par rapport à aux
produits
des produits qui sont plus mis sur le
devant comme l'innovation c'est que la
balance n'est pas positive je veux dire
on peut faire beaucoup plus de volume si
les prix ne sont pas adaptés et la
question est pas de dire qu'il faut
multiplier par par 50 le prix de ces
produits là mais la santé c'est aussi
les premiers soins c'est aussi la santé
du quotidien c'est aussi la prévention
et aujourd'hui notre politique de prix
elle est pas très incitative c'est tout
ce que je peux vous dire pour compléter
ce propos là si on veut faire plus de
volume de points de vue industriels moi
je parle en tant qu'industriel il faut
effectivement augmenter nos capacités
c'est le cas de NICOPASS mais on a aussi
un autre produit pour lequel on a
investi une votre capacité pour répondre
à la demande sur les produits matures
malgré ça c'est toujours pareil un coût
c'est des nouvelles installations c'est
des temps de de validation et des
grosses de dossier de variation qui font
que si on n'a pas cette visibilité c'est
stabilité là et si on voit au contraire
des prix avec un potentiel de
décroissance dans le futur on se pose la
question de dire est-ce qu'il faut
vraiment y aller et ça c'est très
clairement le groupe Pierre Fabre
aujourd'hui est très implanté en France
et souhaite continuer à avoir cette
production en France ça c'est clair il y
a pas il y a pas il y a pas il y a pas
de souci par rapport à ça mais du coup
en comparaison d'autres zones de
production ou régions de production
c'est clair que l'Europe et la France en
particulier a des surcos qui sont des
surcoûts structurels qui sont qui sont
clairement et qui doivent être à un
moment donné pour pouvoir être compensé
par une visibilité par une stabilité qui
est qui est compliqué aujourd'hui et on
disait sur les problématiques de rupture
qu'on a eu il y a des des causes
exogènes donc le covid je dirais
maintenant la la crise sur les matières
premières et autres mais il y a aussi
une cause qui est comme comme on l'a dit
de prudence dans l'investissement sur
les produits matures et on voit ça avec
le paracétamol par exemple même si
aujourd'hui il y a un nouveau site qui
se met en place dans l'Isère mais on a
vu ça pourquoi le paracétamol est parti
parce que effectivement les coûts de
production étaient plus plus facile plus
simple plus plus rapide et moins moins
élevé que ce qu'on avait en France
d'aller dans des pays plus éloignés
[Musique]
les dates de péremption de péremption
vous pouvez les allonger novice je sais
pas comment
des produits ça dépend des produits
parce que ça ça peut aussi avoir une
logique par rapport au stock ou pas en
général on est entre 24 et 36 mois de
péremption c'est en fait on fait des
tests de ce qu'on appelle les tests de
stabilité on va mettre en stabilité des
produits et on va voir au bout de deux
mois six mois huit mois et ainsi de
suite si la quantité de principes actif
qui est décrite dans le dossier
d'enregistrement et toujours suffisant
pour avoir le l'indication thérapeutique
du médicament mais en général les les
péremptions sont relativement long c'est
pas le le point il est pas il est pas là
on a vraiment dans les ruptures pour ce
qui nous concerne on a vraiment des
causes qui ont été des courges
exceptionnel le covid personne l'a voulu
on a eu ce Stop and Go ou tout s'est
arrêté il faut se rappeler aussi que la
Chine a été bloquée pendant encore un an
après que nous en Europe et dans les
pays occidentaux on avait redémarré un
peu une activité même si elle était pas
à fond donc on a eu ce covid là on a eu
du coup derrière l'effet l'effet rebond
de la crise sur les matières parce que
tout le monde a voulu beaucoup plus de
choses que ce que les industriels
pouvaient proposer et après il y a le
côté vraiment structurel de fond c'est
de dire quelle visibilité à ton pour
pouvoir investir sur sur de la
production en France sur l'augmentation
de capacité de produits matures pour
lesquelles clairement on n'est pas dans
des marges qui sont les mêmes que celles
de produits hyper hyper innovants très
très clairement mais malgré tout on se
rend compte que il y a besoin d'avoir
aussi ce cette balance là sur les
produits très innovants et les produits
qui sont plus comme tu l'as dit
Vincent de première nécessité
on a l'impression que c'est plus c'est
pas tellement le problème du prix qui
vous inquiète c'est plus la visibilité à
5 ans ou à 8 ans ou à 10 ans c'est à
dire la vision de l'Industrielle quoi
OK
messieurs un grand merci
à vous